[Music]
on this monday night confusion over new
travel rules
what do we do the need to clear the air
and why some international passengers
didn't have to quarantine at a hotel
today
the shot of optimism in nova scotia it's
nothing to it it's just a little prick
in the arm
plus when canada will receive its
largest delivery of the vaccine
overworked and underpaid it's tiring
sometimes you're on call 24 hours a day
seven days a week
the broken system of caring for critical
infrastructure in first nations
communities
and stunning new sights and sounds from
mars
the parachute has deployed a front row
seat as perseverance plummets to the red
planet
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with news about vaccines and
what could be a pivotal week
the public health agency of canada says
the largest delivery of vaccines is
on the way
planes carrying the precious cargo began
arriving in canada early this morning
more than 600 thousand doses are
expected to arrive
this week the majority over 475
thousand doses are coming from pfizer
biontech another 168
000 are being shipped from moderna
at the same time new rules are in effect
for anyone entering canada for
non-essential reasons
they must show proof of a negative covid
test done in the last 72 hours
and now at land borders self swab covid
19 test kits are being handed out
at all 117 points of entry on site covid
19 testing is being provided at five
high-volume border points the plan is to
expand that to 16 sites by march 4th
a two-week quarantine is still mandatory
and a second test is required on
day 10. travelers coming in by air will
also be tested on arrival
and must quarantine at a
government-designated hotel for three
days at their own expense
it sounds like a simple plan but the
devil is in the details
robin gill has our top story tonight
there are 10 to 15 international flights
landing at vancouver international
airport daily
these passengers arriving from china
early monday were told
they didn't have to check into a
quarantine hotel not to
hotel that's because the new rules
kicked in
after they were already in the air
number the federal government's handout
gives the impression the new travel
rules
are seamless but travelers can't book
directly with approved hotels
they have to go through the federal
government's 1-800 line
and rely on civil servants to make the
reservations
bilal galini who's been working in paris
is preparing to come back to montreal
he spent hours calling with no luck what
do we do does it mean that we are not
allowed to travel back to
to canada the bc center for disease
control keeps track of travel exposures
there are more coven 19 exposures on
domestic flights
compared to international arrivals but
the more transmissible variants
are the variable here this doesn't
account for that many cases
all things considered but we do want to
limit the entry
of new variants up until now the new
variants have come
from other countries upon further
investigation gallini saw that he can't
book until two days in advance
and his flight isn't until march still
he thought he was doing due diligence
you have only also a finite number of
rooms available
so suppose you call 48 hours in advance
only
and you want to book your hotel suppose
you get
through to someone who will guarantee
you that you have rooms available
it seems the new travel rules have added
another layer of pandemonium and panic
in this pandemic if we are not ready we
should figure out how to get ready as
quickly as possible
and have an alternate plan that is not
leaving it to the passengers themselves
to just decide to do the right thing and
self-isolate
even after the three days at the hotel
travelers still must self-isolate at
home for
another 11 days that's if there's a
negative test but if there's a positive
one
they have to move on to a
government-approved facility and
quarantine
donna robin gill at vancouver
international airport
thanks in british columbia the teachers
union is calling for immediate action to
prevent the spread of new variants in
schools and
potentially into the homes of students
and staff the bc teachers federation
wants masks made mandatory in all
classes including elementary schools and
wants increased rapid testing when
variants appear in schools
the bc government says existing
recommendations are working and
transmission in schools remains low at
least seven schools in the metro
vancouver area have now reported
exposures to the highly transmissible
variant
first detected in the uk those schools
have remained open and close contacts of
the infected individuals have been told
to self-isolate and get tested
in quebec four schools have closed as a
precaution
because cases of the variance are
suspected but not confirmed
testing there is underway across canada
more than 800 cases of covid19 variants
have now been confirmed
the majority involved the b117 the uk
variant
every country is trying to work out how
to handle these variants
today prime minister boris johnson laid
out his plan to cautiously ease his
country out of a nationwide lockdown
we're now traveling on a one-way road
to freedom
the plan is to reopen in four phases in
the uk starting march 8th with the
reopening of schools
dates to lift other restrictions are not
set in stone and all the legal limits on
social gatherings and contacts will be
lifted no earlier than june 21st
johnson says the decisions will be
determined by data
not dates the data out of the u.s today
is
grim half a million americans have now
died from covet 19.
that is the number of confirmed deaths
the real number could be even higher
few american presidents understand lost
the way president joe biden does and
tonight he joined the nation
in mourning this nation will smile again
this nation will know sunny days again
this nation will know joy again
and as we do we'll remember each person
we've lost
the lives they lived the loved ones are
left behind
we will get through this i promise you
biden led a moment of silence for what
he called a heartbreaking loss of life
it is the highest death toll of any
country in the world
many of those who died took their last
breath alone
biden said the world cannot become numb
to the sorrow
as jackson proskow reports families
across the country
are grieving from the moment they met
until the moment they died manuel and
sally montano were together
they succumbed to the virus on the same
day in the same hospital room
after spending their 50th anniversary
side by side
on ventilators it's difficult to lose
one of your parents let alone both of
them
it's devastating nobody was ever
prepared for that
covid has shattered lives in every
corner of the u.s
detroit bus driver jason hargrove new
york nurse
kais kelly new mom erica becerra
just 33 years old she gave birth to her
son
but didn't get to hold him
because right after she gave birth
that's when they put the tube in the
first death in the u.s
was just over one year ago half of all
deaths since then
a quarter million have occurred in just
the past three months
this is the equivalent of the city of
atlanta
in terms of deaths and in a year's time
the failures began with the trump
administration which shunned science and
sowed mistrust about public health
measures
all without a national plan yet for the
first time in the pandemic
there are signs of optimism i don't
think it's inevitable
that we will have a surge but we need to
be prepared
there's hope that new more contagious
variants may not take hold
cases and deaths have fallen sharply and
the u.s has already administered
more vaccinations than any other nation
63 million doses to date
at a rate nearly five times faster than
canada
we should be getting more and more
vaccines into arms as quickly as
possible
because the more people that are
vaccinated the the less damage
these variants can do no matter how or
when it all ends
hundreds of thousands of families will
be forever scarred by loss
as the virus exacts a higher toll in the
u.s
than in any other country on earth
jackson prosko
global news washington allegations
against canada's former top soldier are
back in the spotlight
in ottawa house of commons defense
committee met to look into what the
government did and did not know about
allegations of sexual misconduct
against former chief of the defense
staff general jonathan vance
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson is continuing to follow this
story for us mercedes
what happened today donna the government
is grappling with
how to handle an investigation that
senior sources call
unprecedented in scope and seriousness
after major kelly brennan's interview
with global news the probe won't just
look at the allegations against general
john vance
but also who was complicit and barriers
the women face to coming forward
and a new concern that sexual misconduct
may be a larger issue at the senior
ranks of the canadian forces
major brennan explained the problem with
powerful officers having relationships
with their subordinates
as she related how she says she felt
with general vance
was i participating in it
yes could i say no to him no
and the reason why i say that is because
if he rang me on the phone or if he
texted me
i was obliged to get back to him well
the terms of reference for the external
investigation are still being developed
there are a few ways that investigation
this extensive and this sensitive can be
handled
either a large human resources firm or a
prominent canadian
like a former supreme court justice
according to one source who is familiar
with the file
military police said that they can't
comment on ongoing investigations
after major brennan said she was
violently attacked by a member of the
military
who has not been identified publicly or
whether they have opened an
investigation
into a former boss who brennan said
asked her for sex
but was promoted instead of reprimanded
a senior defense source told us
police are expected to open additional
investigations
there are questions about why the
liberal government didn't do more today
at the committee hearings
into the allegations against vance
lawyer michel drapeau disputed defense
minister harjit sajin's claim
that there was nothing more he could
have done he had in fact the judy
and the facility if he wanted to to have
them out
investigated he could have appointed one
of the military judge
as a board of inquiry and get to the
bottom of it and then act on it
the committee has now summoned gary
walburn the former military ombudsman
who warned sajin about the allegations
against vance
in 2018. vance has denied all
allegations
of inappropriate behavior donna okay
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
the house of commons has voted to
declare what's happening to the
minority muslim uighur population in
china a genocide
the motion was put forward by the
conservatives who called on the liberals
to send a united message
about human rights no mps voted against
it but
not everyone voted for it the case in
canada's relationship with china
is complicated abigail beeman is
following the developments abigail
how did today's vote unfold well donna
the motion passed
late this afternoon mps voted in favor
266 to zero
that means more than 70 people abstain
from voting including the prime minister
who wasn't there
and the entire liberal cabinet many
liberal backbenchers did vote in favor
and an amendment put forward by the bloc
quebecois also passed
calling on the international olympic
committee to move the 2022 beijing
olympics if
china doesn't change its practices
they were torturing beating them
insulting them making them crawl like
dogs
and not hesitating killing them too
speaking through an interpreter calvin
tursun says she is a concentration camp
witness a lucky one who got out she says
with relatives still in weaker detention
camps in china
in 2019 as any other legal women i was
fortunately sterilized
after waiting in line for four hours my
turn
i have became permanently handicapped
i would not forget this painful
experience forever
several hundred eagle women became
sterile at the same time with me
as i speak right now i'm feeling the
post-surgical pain in my body
we can no longer ignore this we must
call it for what it is
a genocide mps were asked if they were
concerned the two canadians detained by
china michael coverage and michael
spavor could become collateral damage if
we allow arbitrary detention to deter
genocide recognition then no canadian is
safe no canadian abroad
ahead of the vote the chinese embassy in
ottawa expressed its strong
dissatisfaction and firm opposition in a
statement
saying the claims against them are
disinformation and lies
and there is no so-called genocide
forced sterilization
forced labor or re-education camps they
have no alternative to denying what is
going on because admission would just
make things worse on their end
however unfortunately we have a lot of
evidence
mounting witness evidence camp survivors
and others
the timing of this vote is significant
it comes on the eve of the first
bilateral meeting between prime minister
justin trudeau and u.s president joe
biden trudeau and biden will meet
virtually tuesday afternoon
members of their cabinet will too a
canadian government source tells global
news the cases of coverg and spawn as
well as mung won joe are expected to
come up
but is part of a broader conversation
around china and human rights
donna important conversation abigail
beeman in ottawa thanks
they perform pivotal work but barely
make ends meet
coming up the struggle of workers
responsible for critical water
infrastructure on first nations
plus can they stay secret the u.s
supreme court rules on former president
trump's tax returns
tonight we take a deeper look at the
water crisis affecting first nations
across this country
the workers responsible for maintaining
critical infrastructure are often low
paid and are on call
24 7. a year-long investigation led by
global news aptn concordia's institute
for investigative journalism
discovered how outdated funding
structures have led
to a cascade of problems here's
elizabeth mcsheffrey
when something goes wrong at tobik first
nations aging water treatment plant
greg brewer's phone is often the first
to ring it's satisfying
it's tiring at some times because you
know you're on call 24 hours a day seven
days a week
all year long brewer is part of the last
line of defense for a system that
delivers water to 2500 residents
and yet he makes less than 20 dollars an
hour
it's stressful but i mean i guess like
anything else
if you do it long enough you get used to
it and you just
live your life with it global news aptn
the institute for investigative
journalism and journalism
students across the country surveyed 122
first nations from coast to coast
we found two-thirds of their water
operators earn less than the median wage
of other operators in their province
some earn less than half that wage and
some earn close to minimum wage
we sacrifice our salaries to pay for our
third operator
so it doesn't really add to too much
it's more of a favor here in the
maritimes we spoke with operators who
work
full-time on call around the clock for
as little as 13 dollars an hour
first nations say there just isn't
enough funding to go around meaning
tough decisions need to be made on how
the money is spent our own source
revenue is
taking a hit this year so for that we
have to pick and choose it's
overwhelming i guess like to think that
something should be more simple and it's
not the federal government hasn't
updated its funding formula for water
and wastewater treatment needs in 23
years
the situation they find themselves in is
is unacceptable this is perhaps the
the more the more important discussion
around sovereignty over critical
infrastructure
while additional funding is on the way
some are pursuing a new solution on the
east coast
certainly the theme of water is
fundamental to first nations
and they felt it was time to get beyond
the
year-to-year kind of focus of trying to
operate
a system and take a more long-term
approach
last year the atlantic first nations
water authority signed a historic
framework
that will finally allow its members to
control their own infrastructure
the plan is to be up and running by 2022
setting an example that could be adopted
anywhere in canada
elizabeth mcsheffrey global news halifax
still ahead a pair of frightening
aviation incidents and the company
linked
to both
another boeing plane this time the
triple seven has been grounded after
this catastrophic engine failure on a
united airlines flight
shortly after takeoff from denver on
saturday the flight landed
safely u.s regulators have issued an air
worthiness directive for stepped up
inspections of the hollow fan blades
unique to the boeing triple sevens pratt
and whitney engine
initial findings show two fan blades
fractured
causing the engine to blow up
in the netherlands an engine on a boeing
747
caught fire shortly after takeoff two
people on the ground were injured by
metal parts that fell from the cargo
plane
several cars and homes were also damaged
the 747 was on route to new york city
when it happened
it was re-routed and made a safe landing
in belgium
the cause is under investigation the u.s
supreme court has declined to block a
grand jury from getting former president
donald trump's personal
and corporate tax returns his tax tax
returns are still subject to secrecy
rules and won't be made public at this
point but
they could be if the manhattan district
attorney brings criminal charges at some
future date and seeks to introduce them
as evidence
trump has tried to shield his taxes
since the 2016 election campaign
up next nova scotia's game plan for
community vaccination
nova scotia has endured a year of
tragedy all under the cloud of covid 19.
one bright spot is how the province has
kept its infection numbers lower than
much of the country
as ross lord tells us that's made for a
more laid-back atmosphere as the
province begins its community
vaccination program
starting with seniors like most elderly
canadians
bernice burns hasn't been getting out
much in the past year
i do go and get my own groceries i don't
stay in the store very long
because i'm a bit afraid at my age of
you know maybe picking something up
on this outing burns is picking up
something inspirational
the first of two doses of vaccine at a
community vaccine clinic for residents
aged 80 and older it's nothing to it
it's just a little prick in the arm and
i'm sure i'm going to be all right
in a province that's avoided major
outbreaks since last spring
this clinic is a chance to learn the
best way to vaccinate people on mass
in a less stressful atmosphere in coming
weeks
more community clinics will open after
ages 80 and over are immunized
clinics will target younger residents
moving down by
five-year increments at a time a
measured approach
a rolling out vaccine knowing that we
don't have
the same type of pressure to immunize as
quickly as possible as other provinces
for those on the receiving end the
needles are liberating
it's a christmas gift that doesn't have
to be wrapped mary poole
says since last march she's ventured out
of her apartment
only 10 times armed with newfound
security
she's eager to get moving a better
chance of living an extra year
to get older around i might be old
dancing again if things get better
hope that the year ahead will be an
improvement
ross lord global news
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with some stunning new video and
audio from nasa's perseverance rover
press events announced slowed to
subsonic speeds and the heat shield has
been separated
this camera gives you a front row seat
as the rover hurtled to the surface of
mars last week it entered the upper
atmosphere at 20
100 kilometers an hour and perseverance
is also lending us
its ears
nasa says a microphone picked up that
it's a faint wind gust they say on mars
and they say it's the first ever sound
recording from mars
nasa says it wanted to take the public
along for the ride
of a lifetime thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow take care
of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
you